[Music]  this is major royally bride I'm  attempting to reach dr. Clifford McBride  this is dr. McBride son  dad I'd like to see you again  [Music]  I recall how we used to watch black my  movies together musicals were favorable  I remember you tutoring me in math  [Music]  instilled in me a strong work ethic  you should know I've chosen a career  that you would approve of I've dedicated  my life to the exploration of space and  I thank you for that  [Music]  what is happening out there is a crisis  of unknown magnitude  [Music]  we believe your father may be involved  my father's dead what exactly are you  requiring for me  exploration is know is a noble venture  we have to hold out the possibility that  your father may be hiding from us  [Music]  we have a job to do are you ready I'm  ready  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]